I mean I just chose books that I like
that I thought reflected the way the
characters saw themselves as writers so
I thought Greg Kinnear is character
would love Cheever and Carver and that's
the kind of books that he would read and
who he would think that he was that kind
of writer and so rusty loves Stephen
King because he's a teenager and that's
what I loved when I was a teenager and
Logan his character loves all the
mystery and crime writers so what
happens if if Stephen King doesn't say
he's going to be in the movie what do
you do then I've been very very bad yeah
it was uh
I love Stephen King when I was a
teenager and I was raised by very
Christian parents he used to burn his
books in the fireplace if they found
them and you pulled him out and that was
the most water I hit I hit him in the
box springs under my bed I remember one
summer laying under my bed like hitting
the stand and so yeah I loved his stuff
a lot and I wrote him a letter when I
was 12 and sent him some books to sign
and he sent him back to me and wrote me
a beautiful letter and so I got to go
back to him all these years later and
just say I'm gonna make a movie would
you please come be in it and I was lucky
enough that he's really nice and he said
sure and did it and it was great I still
remember the day that my producer Judy
Kyra called me and said I'm going to be
your favorite person when I tell you
what I'm gonna tell you and it's like
what are you gonna tell me and she's
like I got Stephen King and I was like
and I'll never forget you called me
right after crying on the phone it was
bad
cry when he got you I think I was crying
yeah I I remember where I was I was in a
nail salon and I was sitting down and I
had fought for this for what like six
months seven months I really wanted it
and I remember sitting there and and my
agent said to me I'm I have good news
and bad news good news is you got
writers bad news is you can't do it then
why can't I do it because it was exactly
the same time as a press tour of mine
but we did the press tour while she did
our movie so she took how many flights
in and out I took 23 flights during this
shoot during the filming of this movie
yeah always knew her lions always on
time
I I when I read the script it was the
first time and since then it's been the
only time I've ever read something that
I couldn't imagine somebody else playing
and whatever
took whether I was tired or it didn't
matter for me for this project I grew up
watching movies my best friend and I
were like the little kids in super 8 and
we just made movies growing up on video
and we went to see every movie and
watched every movie and studied
director's careers and listened to
laserdisc commentaries back in the day
and DVD commentaries and that's kind of
how we educated ourselves I guess and I
mean I wrote my first script when I was
in high school and we just tried to make
that and just kept writing ever since
and had projects that almost happened
that we had actors attached to that just
didn't happen and then this one and
worked out and it was like pushing the
snow ball up a hill for 10 years and
then it just started to roll down by
itself but that was that's kind of what
it felt like the first time our first
meeting he's like just be my dream to
get Jennifer Connelly but that would
just never happen it's like every time I
mentioned that Josh Boone was like a
first time writer director everyone goes
how the heck did he get that cast like
how did he get a movie made so so so
well done with amazing producers an
amazing team an amazing Tim or like I
think you should ask him he's right here
no it was you know it was amazing and
I'll never forget the first day of set
though like Josh would you'd sit behind
the camera like right in all of our eye
lines and you just be sitting there like
like this and we'd be in the middle of a
scene it was like there were days when
you go okay this is gonna be we're all
gonna have like a fun time and you go my
god he's so brilliant like how can this
be your first time I'm like Forrest Gump
it's like sometimes there's brilliance
and other times I'm immoral but just the
way that it all came together I've known
that since he was 8
NAT knew Liana before I had just done a
film with Greg before like so we all
kind of had this very like familial vibe
anyway and we shot in such a small place
and we all lived pretty much together
and by the end of it it was like leaving
summer camp we were all so upset it was
very emotional we all went bowling well
you know there was like that much to do
and eating people shoot in big cities
and they can go home where were you
shooting you don't we shot him
Wilmington North Carolina which was
beautiful and we had amazing crews and
it was just really cool when everybody
kind of had to bond because we all live
together in the same hotel and got up in
that breakfast together every day and
well it's funny I also have always loved
writing I started writing for magazines
at 15 so journalism and expressing
myself through words has always been
something I felt really close to I'm
obviously not as permissibly that's why
I was impressed about that when we met
the first time I remember you tell me
that it's like you published in all
these magazines great we connected a lot
on writing from the get-go but I think
Samantha I remember first reading the
script going way all of her monologues
are so all over the place and they're so
witty and smart and but she doesn't
think about what she's saying she just
spews out information that's coming from
such a deep place of mistrust and fear
and whether it was in love or her family
or just the world in general and the way
that she writes is so cynical and and
yet she's so smart but she just rants
and rants and rants so of course as an
actor going through that knowing I have
four hours on a plane that I could
memorize this before I fall asleep to go
do whatever I'm I'm memorized lines like
two months in advance and set them over
and over and over in a mirror so that
they became so boring that I could just
stand there and just spew out the line
at the beginning to the frat-boy because
it just didn't she didn't care for me
music set the tone for everything I
brought music to the actors and Bale had
mixed CDs waiting for them in their
hotel rooms when they got there and that
was how I made sure all the actors were
on the same page what did they listen to
I mean what were the kinds of things in
the movie that was written into it
bright eyes there's bright eyes songs in
it his band did the score
a lot of the songs that were written in
the script the between the bars Elliott
Smith song certainly it was in the
script he had come up with little care
packages for each of us as our
characters so we had a CD of music that
Sam would listen to or and a book for
each actor to read that really resembled
their character and it was like it was
really cool to have a director that
cared so much that you know to
understand this is who you're this is
the essence of your character and now
like take it and run it was a very very
warm thing to walk into do you remember
the book
you